sur le pont de Crimée les enquêteurs
russes prennent des notes et cherchent
des indices les autorités ont rapidement
ouvert une enquête pour terrorisme et
pour le président Vladimir Poutine les
responsables sont tout trouvés
[Musique]
d'un acte terroriste visant à détruire
une infrastructure civile russe
d'importance critique
les auteurs les exécutants et les
commanditaires sont les services secrets
Ukrainiens de son côté Kiev n'a pas
démenti ni confirmé son implication dans
l'explosion qui a endommagé le pont
reliant la Crimée à la Russie se
contentant d'ironiser sur les déboires
de Moscou les autorités ukrainiennes ont
en revanche dénoncé les derniers
bombardements russes sur un quartier
résidentiel de zaporiggia qui ont fait
plusieurs victimes volody merzelinski
accusa son tour Moscou de terrorisme la
désignation officielle de la Russie
comme est un terroriste et nécessaire à
tous les niveaux il faut une claire à
tous les niveaux de chaque escalade
russe cela va des attaques terroristes
aux tentatives criminelles d'annexer
notre territoire
un appel lancé à l'ONU qui tient une
réunion d'urgence ce lundi sur les
annexes en Ukraine dans le même temps le
président russe convoque son Conseil de
sécurité rassemblant ses principaux
ministres alors que sur le terrain ces
troupes subissent toujours d'importants
revers
et